hello everyone and welcome to another HD
tutorial and in this episode not exactly
by request but I just thought I would
show you guys how to get the camstudio
lossless codec if you're still using
camstudio as your screen recorder now
I've had there's been more than one
incident where people have come to me
with questions about the Dybbuk six
point eight point five codec or they've
had a small problem with actually
recording their screen and so i've
recommended the camstudio lossless codec
actually has not alternative for the
DivX codec so what we're gonna do in
order to get this codec is open up any
web browser and I'm just gonna use
Safari again just because of its speed
and you can use any popular search
engine and just type in camstudio this
is actually going to be found at camp
Studios website camstudio org so i'm
just gonna click on that and we're gonna
scroll about halfway down the page until
we find the camstudio the camstudio
lossless codec version 1.4 now you can
either get the exe executable or the
Doug zip I prefer that yet see it's just
one step less I'll have to do is click
on it and it will open in its own window
saying do you want to save this file I
hit open I just hit the open button in
order to open the Installer and I'm 99%
confident that it will automatically
throw itself into camstudio because
that's all it's done for so you don't
have any more installation steps you
follow a very very quick installation
process and that is about it so if you
have the latest version of camstudio and
go ahead and download the camstudio
lossless codec if you've been having any
problems with the difficut ik and that
is about it for you guys so I hope you
enjoyed this each tutorial and if you do
have any requests like I said I'm gonna
open you just give you a little sneak
peek this is all the video ideas I have
yet to do okay so I'm going to minimize
that I have a ton of video ideas left
for you guys go ahead and subscribe so
you can get that daily update that Tech
Talk every week and that's about it so
thanks for watching and subscribe peace